revisit boston's 92 to 87 win
over the raptors to close out that
series they win it uh
four games to three um man what a uh
what a night jason tatum what a night it
was
and i think that probably the best news
for you i'm just guessing this
would be um boy you don't have
you don't have a game on saturday you've
been playing every other day you got
three days off now to rest up after what
was a rugged series
yeah uh that was that was tough i got to
tip my head off to
to the raptors um you know they made us
work they made us earn that
and i think that's what makes it you
know feel so much better you know we we
earned it
you know game seven want to go home and
we competed that's all you can ask for
and uh just gotta get ready for the next
one
everybody up here on this panel except
ernie has been through a game seven so
could you explain to me your
emotions last night did you watch
netflix you watch hulu
were you nervous what you thinking about
the game what were your emotions last
night coming into this game today
uh yeah this is my third third game
seven i've been in
um you know for me i really couldn't
sleep last night
you know push the game back to nine
couldn't take a nap
uh you know i was just i was just ready
to go uh
because you know it's it's when to go
home and i i wasn't ready to pack my
clothes up yet
um you know we gotta come at the
mentality that
you know it's us to them and i think
that's what we had tonight and everybody
contributed
that was a big win for us
you know obviously we look at your team
and we look at
you jaylen and kimball as terrific
offensive players
but tell us about marcus bart and tice
them two guys just come out there and
just beat the hell out of people they're
fun to watch
what's it like to watch that every day
yes i said
i saw the other day shaq didn't even
know my man type's name
[Laughter]
man tyson has been unbelievable
unbelievable for us
this season and you know smart is
first team all defense um the best
defender in the league in my opinion
he made the the play of the series
getting that block on power with 30 some
seconds left
um and you know smart just make those
plays that don't really show up in the
stat book but you know can change the
series change
the dynamic of a game and uh if you if
you're going to war if you're in a game
seven
you know that's who you wanted your team
jason congratulations
and uh firstly uh secondly
you know let's shift gears to miami you
know i i looked at the
the toronto this series against toronto
and said
you know you guys had such a height
advantage on the perimeter at that time
even when pyro came into the game
but now when you play miami the size is
different what's the
different approach that you will have
against the
jimmy butlers and the tyler heroes and
and all of the rest of the
a little bit more size on the perimeter
yeah
uh you know they they're bigger than us
for the most part and uh you know
they're a great team well coach
they got some great players and they
compete um
you know so i think toronto is a great
test for us because
you know toronto they they compete as
hard as as anybody
and they make you bring it every night
um you know so
going toe to toe going seven with them
um i think
you know really help us going forward
next round um because we're here to
compete for a championship
so uh a couple days off of help and just
gotta get ready for
miami jason knowing how much uh kobe
bryant meant to you
um what does it mean when you hear that
you're the second youngest guy to have a
25
10 and five game seven behind
only kobe oh
um i didn't know that that's
i mean that's that's great great company
being everybody knows
you know how much he he meant to myself
how much he meant
to this world to the game of basketball
obviously you know
shaq and those guys um you know
obviously anytime you mention you know
with somebody like that
means you're doing something good uh but
you know for me i just
just try to get better every day every
game just try to improve
you know i really look at you know i'm
one of the young guys i just try to
you know be the best player on the court
every night and i think that's the
mentality i take
every every time i step on the floor
jason i've been watching you
somebody sent me a couple videos of you
down there on the golf course
i tell you give me five and five name
your price i'll fly down when this is
over
five aside brother let's go for it let
me know i've seen your golf swing i like
my chances
[Laughter]
and hey when this is over he's not
staying in the bubble i don't know he's
gonna be the first place he's gonna be
without the bubbles
jason we uh appreciate you repping the
uh the st louis cardinals see the hat
and i know you've been uh
putting lou brock's name on your shoes
too man appreciate that he was a classic
congratulations brother yep appreciate
it thank you
boston celtics winners over the toronto
raptors 92.
ernie to 87 kenny am i right am i wrong
when you're on the list with kobe bryant
and jerry west you did something pretty
good
uh i think that's a list you want to be
on